without hai north american league of
legends would be completely different
hai is the nalcs's original shot caller
the league's first real leader whose
unique shot calling style and macro play
got cloud9 into the lcs and
desperately for some kind of leader to
put them back together
he's basically the puppeteer of cloud9
he is the chess master
while he'll always be known as the heart
and soul of cloud9 league of legends
he's recently taken on a leadership role
with some of the league's newer
organizations
hai is a league of legends mastermind
and when his shot calling was at its
peak
there was no way an n a team could beat
him that's gonna be a trip to the world
championship for cloud nine
this is his story
hi hi dulan was born on september 20th
1992 in grandville michigan and took to
video games along with his brothers
hai played warcraft 3 counter-strike
dota
and wow before discovering league of
legends in 2010.
by the time he was in college hai was
near the top of the solo queue ladder
and a hot commodity for teams looking to
make a mark on the competitive scene
with a star jungle
team usa will win wcg
2010 in league of legends as the nexus
falls high form team
no fear which was quickly signed by
orbit gaming
but later turned to reddit for funding
after they left the org
your team formally orbits now reddit
nation how did that happen
uh basically our owner is a scumbag so
we're kind of pissed out
and we went on reddit and asked people
if they could help us get here and they
sent us here hai's big personality and
cocky attitude earned him a lot of fans
but the team struggled on land wild
turtle force to come back up krepo going
in with the flash
unstoppable force in the shadows he
won't do anything as he gets crushed
down
and it does not look good is reddit
nation actually looking to push out
wicked here they do drop down kog'maw
they do drop down lemon nation
and they will be going in for the fight
they just had to reposition themselves
they dropped the inhibitor in a
beautiful second game by counter logic
europe as they take the first matchup of
lone star 2.
after some key losses hai left for cloud
nine
alongside his right hand man derrick
lemonation heart
and made it all the way to the first
ever nalcs qualifier
it is going to be cloud 9 vs maan and
frankly
i think this is the best game of the
group i mean this is definitely a very
good game we've got the highly rated x
nom nom x quantic now cloud9 names
they've had
good names and they're they're just
everyone thinks they're gonna get all
the way through
but the team fell out of the tournament
in the group stage this
looks like the end for cloud nine's
journey at the regionals azure
will be moving on riv and were dropped
by cloud9
they were too cocky and needed to
rebuild
we learned a lot from that tournament
let me first start off saying
that we went into that tournament
expecting we were going to
qualify and make it through pai switched
to the mid lane
and he and lemon eventually recruited
balls meteos and sneaky to fill out the
team
with high calling the shots it was hai's
last chance
since i couldn't attend school i had one
more shot to try and qualify
and i told myself if i didn't make it to
that one i would just attend school
again
in that summer slash fall so i pretty
much
said if i don't qualify i'll go back to
school and if i do
then we'll see where it takes me high
was the brains of the operation
while elimination was his right-hand man
executing his orders in the bottom lane
the rest of the players were the muscle
together
they were the squad that stole the lcs
out from under the established teams
the team cruised through the qualifier
under the quantic gaming banner
to earn an lcs spot quantic 3-0
going into the lcs summer split and were
quickly resigned by cloud9 ahead of
their lcs debut
cloud 9 bulldozed their way through the
2013
nalcs summer split going 25 and 3 in the
regular season
and swept both team dignitas and team
solomid in the playoffs it's gotta hit
the nexus
with their eyes on the nexus their eyes
on the summer split
completely undefeated as a series 25 and
three
on the split the league was young but no
team in its first season
was quite as dominant as high's cloud9
you guys are flying
as high as can be possible in the lcs
how do you remain humble
how do you not let it get to your head
um
we always just talk to each other and
tell each other not to get cocky not to
get complacent and just remember that
anything can happen
it doesn't matter what how good our
record is it just matters how good we
perform each game
so as captain knowledge just tell us to
chill down relax just it doesn't matter
our record doesn't matter our win streak
just take a game at a time as always
high was developing strategies for the
team that were so far ahead of
anything that north america had come up
with looking to other regions for
inspiration
we watched the koreans and just do what
they do because they won the world
all-stars thing and we think that they
play the best
they brought the macro game and n a to
new levels
no one saw cloud9 coming over 90
win rate on the season which is just
absolutely
unprecedented in the lcs and while they
couldn't quite make their strategies
work at worlds that year
the team returned to crush n a again in
spring 2014.
they are just absolutely taking
everything they can away from tsm
and the win 17-9 your first game for the
north american lcs in the 2014 split
goes to cloud
c9 picked up an equally impressive 24-4
record in the regular season
and yet another 3-0 victory over tsm in
the playoffs
top and hip turret's gone balls could be
joining he's trying to come in from the
side here we go no stunts come in from
the ulti from morgana but there's the
battle especially the back line
wild turtle gonna be locked up two kills
make that four kills
make that almost everyone going down
cloud nine
gonna end the series 3-0 they're gonna
take down the nexus and they're the
north american
to champions but that's when tragedy
struck
hai was rushed to the er and found out
that his lung had collapsed
winning the spring split meant that
cloud9 was heading to all-stars paris
but high wasn't going anywhere well this
sucks and then i started thinking about
like hey
with this condition the pneumothorax am
i able to go to repairs
their first thought is these guys are
competitors like
oh my god this guy can't go to all-stars
with us what are we going to do
and i'm like don't worry about that
right now like let's get high healthy
collapsed lungs are life-threatening if
not treated quickly
they took out most of them on my left
lung i think they cut out like this much
of my lungs
i don't really know but high pulled
through even streaming league of legends
from his hospital bed while hooked up to
a breathing machine
from the moment he got injured he gave
me the list of mids
that he wanted to represent him
throughout every single game
he was sending me messages tell the guys
this they need to hear this
without hai cloud9 floundered at all
stars
losing 2-0 to omg in the semi-finals
there is the rat look at him getting in
on the top side
seeing if you can ever go sneaky going
to get caught down from this one there's
the kill
balls the next target is he gets in
their face lake being smashed away
as he throws down the shockwave sun may
eventually fall here
or maybe not as they completely control
that balls
nexus joints are down the nexus itself
is going to be focused
and omg get themselves into the finals
here
at the all-star invitational hai
returned to c9 for the summer season
but the team began to struggle cloud9
still took first in the regular season
but they posted an 1810 record and were
tied for first with lmq
the gap was closing 34-minute game cloud
nine
gonna take up a couple of more wins at
the end of the week and they
are gonna be your number one team
heading into the playoffs for the north
american lcs
hi here we are again three splits in a
row
regular season first place how does that
feel
it feels great but it's kind of weird
because this wasn't the normal clg so
it's kind of like a weird feeling
i don't feel like we earned it as much
but i'll still take it i guess
and once playoffs rolled around tsm were
finally able to hand cloud9 their first
na series loss
beating them in the grand finals 3-2
team solomid
looking to dethrone cloud9 as the north
american champions
they lay down the wards so they have all
the vision necessary
a 10 to 10 40 minute game 60 000 gold a
piece on each side
and meteos trying his damnedest to stop
it and after all the tension gsm
finds the fight and wild turtle goes
wild right there on that last fight
out playing cloud nine and carrying tsm
in the championship
the ace master
[Applause]
to be the 2014 north american
champions but cloud9 were still great
though younger foreign mid-laners like
sauron bjergsen bjorg and you
xiaowei xiaoxian were more mechanically
sound than hai
he was still the mastermind behind c9's
macro play
and developed a reputation for
micromanaging his players
it's really funny because i've actually
played alongside high and ranked games
before
and in rank fives and he micromanages
everybody
and when he's in the mindset of we're
better than these guys he's constantly
telling you things like
go here do this test that and he's
making sure that you're pushing up
going back you always know what you need
to do so he's
basically the puppeteer of cloud9 he is
the chess master
and when he's in his mindset and he's in
his groove you definitely see it i think
high shot calling became his signature
other teams would make sweeping
general calls while high would give his
players strict directions on what they
should be doing
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
c9 made history that year when they
became the first north american team to
take a game off a korean team at worlds
after beating najin white shield in the
group stage and ga's are coming up here
soon as well
not quite in 10 seconds time though so
this baron might be a little bit delayed
from both sides until they get those
guards in
sneaky coming around after using his qff
it's gonna be cloud night to win this
one they take out watch this
they can go through and win 51 minutes
in cloud9 finds the amazing fight
five for zero ace nothing will stop them
from winning this game and clown nine
takes down shield
nexus going down and cloud9
picking up a massive victory over naji
white shield
c9 did it again by taking a game off of
tournament favorites
samsung blue in the quarterfinals the
turret number two will fall spirits
helpless they can't stop them they're
putting the damage down on the nexus
the rest of samsung blue sport they're
gonna try one last ditch ever
to keep cloud9 on the
but you were right game number one does
go to cloud nine in the best of five
but went on to lose a nail biting game
four in a heartbreaking basis
thank you
[Applause]
i returned to na but he and cloud9
weren't what they used to be
a wrist injury was making it harder for
him to play
and c9 placed second in the 2015 nalcs
spring playoffs
losing 3-1 to tsm tsm needs to wait for
their minions
and less cloud9 over gate is here we go
oh the over engage in
indeed elimination on the outside gets
bounced dyrus he wants it
dives in on the balls the sanguine pool
saves him just at the last second the
1v1 of bjergsen and high
the bike goes down but high is alive and
bjergsen dies to the turrets
turtle now is the focus depth charge and
anchor toss they lock him down with the
passive but he is hopping around
way too much on kalista turtle the
double turtle triple turn la cuadra
could he be coming up with a penta high
stays on the fountain
the quadra kill once again to come up
with team solomid's pivotal win
on the north american spring split and
they will do it once again
the consecutive wins for team solomid
hai was becoming a relic
his unique shot calling style wasn't
being adopted by other teams
his mechanics were falling behind and
his wrist was hurting
more and more as you can see i have like
pain on my wrists and issues with that
so
just like looking at the amount of solo
queue games my teammates were playing
the amount i could
play it just made me feel bad just
because they're putting a lot of effort
to try and get better
and i can't match that effort just
because my body won't let me
so he decided it was time for a change
on april 22nd
2015 cloud9 announced that hai had
retired
just a few days after losing to tsm in
the playoffs
i don't know very many people in the
world that
are happy with being forced to retire
from an injury
where they still have the drive and the
fire to keep competing getting a
retirement sent to you
due to not being able to play it's
depressing in the sense that
you're still good enough to play you
still want to play people still want to
play with you but there are
issues outside of your command
i guess that is stopping you from doing
it that just sucks to not be able to do
what you love to do and are
able to do because of something outside
of the game according to hai's brother
hai cried when he left to see nine house
he left the family he had built two
years ago
he left the team he had led to victory
time and time again
he left the crew that shocked the nalcs
and the world
cloud9 brought on nikolai incarnation
jensen
to replace high in the middle age and c9
took the first game of the split
off tsm and now it's amounts to 15 to 9
45 minutes in over 100 cs behind
incarnation
held his breath in that mid lane making
sure he could make it to the mid
make it to the late with his team dyrus
doing his damnedess here to shut down
cloud nine
who already had the head-to-head against
team solomid and look to stretch it just
a little bit more
45 minutes on the clock tsm trying one
last time to go for broke on the
stoppage
and cloud nine pick up the first win of
the summer split over team solo mid
but things got bad fast cloud9 were
three and seven by week five
putting them dangerously close to
relegation
where cloud9 used to look like a
well-oiled machine they were now
lost without hai's shot calling meteos
is still very much adapting to being the
shot caller and kind of
adapting to like know what to do with
every situation and kind of
having the kind of dominant voice that i
did like high was
first off i was extremely loud and
he was also very like decisive in his
calls like it's like
do this [ __ ] right now and very loud
cloud9 needed to stave off relegation
cloud9 needed someone to bring the team
together and
lead them to victory cloud nine needed
high during that lcs season where i
wasn't playing
they weren't doing too well i think they
were like two
six or two eight or something like that
when
jack messaged me he didn't message me to
ask me to stop in or to play or anything
like that
he just wanted me to look over the
screams and watch their gameplay
but meteos wasn't feeling well at the
time i guess so he asked if he could
step down for one game
and jack was like you know i know you
haven't played jungle i know you haven't
played in a while but if you're
interested we'd really appreciate
if you sub in one game the organization
called in high for one last job
meteos was benched and hai was back in
the jungle the position he played before
qualifying for the nilcs all of a sudden
it was clear
exactly how much high shot calling
mattered
the team was still lagging behind the
rest of the league mechanically
but they managed to pick up three more
wins staving off relegations
and earning a spot in the regional
finals and it looks like they are gonna
be able to grab that seventh place
in 32 minutes cloud nine take down team
eight
hai had another shot at worlds it wasn't
my decision to come back playing but
i knew all my teammates really wanted to
go jack really wanna go like everyone
worked hard
and like there's no way i'm not gonna
have my selfish needs or like wants
rather
to hold back the team so i put that away
and just put my best foot forward to try
and bring us to worlds
and i told jensen that i would do my
best to bring him the world if he can
carry me at worlds right so i did my job
and now it's his turn to do his job
cloud9 entered the gauntlet as the
underdogs mechanically
the team was behind the curve hai had a
wrist injury and he was playing a
position he hadn't played professionally
in
years but that didn't shake his
confidence alright so
they lost their last game and we won our
last game which just happened
so we have the momentum going with us
hopefully we'll carry that through into
the next game
and complete our six step process step
five is be teammate and tabrik and then
step six is world domination
we're a little far from there you know
but it's a six step process
getting there c9 went down 2-0 against
gravity gaming in their first series of
the gauntlet
the first north american regionals looks
like it might be going to gravity
as they're two over cloud9 they look
lost but hai
showed them the way and they are able to
come back from the
2-0 or i should say o2 that gravity put
them in
to go three to two versus gravity in the
first gauntlet game of the north
american summer split cloud nine are
moving on to take on impulse
and then he did it again
here they go nexus turret number one
where's the defense
it's not there impulse had to give up
the base
they gave up the game they give up the
series cloud nine
get the reverse sweep and they're gonna
face team liquid
turret one is gone turret two under fire
piglets up in four
there's the knockouts but there's the
cash
they go a double for sneaky piglets back
up but piglet slowed down
shaq may buy some time phoenix is one
hit away but cannot kill him off
incarnation zones them out that's gonna
be the nexus
that's gonna be the game that's gonna be
a trip to the world championship for
cloud nine
all right i held my promise i brought
you to work
hai came back and took a shaky messy
team
all the way through the gauntlet and
back to the international stage
at worlds people were ready to doubt
cloud9
and chalk their win up to luck what i'm
looking at when i think of hq they play
this very
like they play like gamble there's
always zero consistency is how they play
they always gamble and i feel like
this type of play style is good against
the worst teams as an
lms they don't really have any like
there's only the top two teams
and against cloud9 i feel it's perfect
because they are
all right so they are they are a bad
team and
that's how it is right now and you can
say okay they went through the gauntlet
but at the same time that was not a
challenging gauntlet i mean the teams
that were in that gauntlet
had absolutely fallen apart by that
point it was basically just cloud9
picking up the pieces
but c9 got off to an incredible start
with a 3-0
undefeated week taking games off fnatic
ahq and invictus gaming would you
believe it this is the group
where three teams could have taken first
place but it's cloud nine who did it the
fourth
that no one counted in the seventh place
north american lcs team
the cinderella story is still alive they
are undefeated in the world championship
and cloud9 are 3-0 the team was pulling
out surprise picks
like heisley sin and jensen's vigor
but hey guys well i love this pick this
is like chris so much
but they were playing with the swagger
of the old cloud9
the undefeatable cloud9 well i came into
this
not thinking i was the underdog because
for me i need to think that we are the
best team for me to make the calls that
a winning team would do
so if you go into a game not thinking
you're going to win i'll probably make
like a bad call and not like
i don't know i just assume i'm better
than them even if we're not so i can
make the correct calls
but other teams in the group figured
them out
all the shot calling in the world didn't
make their second week easier
and cloud9 lost four games in a row
including a tiebreaker missing playoffs
for the first time
in the team's history ahq looking for
the play the malfoy doll does not matter
there is no damage
there is no base left there is only
victory for ahq
one final dunk on the other side of the
map it's like he's playing space jam
and ahq will be the final team
out of group b hai returned to na
defeated but vindicated his team got
dismantled at worlds but he
showed that he was the driving force
behind most of their success
his micro management shot calling style
completely
changed the team for better and worse
hai was moved to support for the 2016
spring split
and cloud9 said they were going to
divide time between him
and michael bunny fufu kurlienko but
after bunny started in two losses in
that split
and they take down cloud nine only
giving up five kills
c9 started high for the rest of the
games
it was again the shot calling without
hai they were a mess they fell down to
ninth place without him and then decided
they had to take out meteos just to get
high back in there
on the team doing that shot calling i
mean they had a 58
win rate with high that year and a 30
win rate without himself
and even though they did the impossible
with him in charge
cloud9 needed to learn how to play
without him
hai was the mastermind behind the team
but he was also the crutch
they kept leaning on cloud9 placed fifth
sixth in the playoffs that split better
than they did without hai
but a far cry from their former
dominance 30 minutes into the game
team solomid take the quarterfinal match
against cloud9
the team needed to lose him they needed
to rebuild
and push hai and his crew far away
from their starting roster high
lemonation and balls
were moved on to cloud9's challenger
roster
they were bumped down to the lower
divisions their team could easily
bulldoze the minor leagues and even earn
an extra lcs plot that cloud9 could sell
and then maybe do it all over again i
wasn't going to retire again
he knew he was good he wanted to get
back on stage
just yesterday i'm sitting in this chair
right here i'm watching worlds i'm
seeing people playing like
you know it brings a bit of envy out of
me whereas
if i was a bit better at the game i
would be able to be there and play
and it's like a goal of every player to
be on that stage
and that's definitely still something
that i want c9c
won the challenger series that split and
earned that lcs spot
once again they leveraged their veteran
experience
to run circles around the younger
players in the league
the mimic is off cooldown there he goes
that's the ace nexus start number one
goes down seven seconds for gbm next to
turn number two being tanked by contract
falls cloud9 challenger on the nexus
are going to do it 3-0
they get that spot in the lcs what a
dominant performance from cloud
nine as they make it a clean sweep
lemon and balls wanted back in they
wanted another chance to prove that they
were worth it
but hi i claimed he was ready to retire
i feel kind of old you know my wrist
kind of hurt my back kind of hurts
and uh i've played a lot already but for
my teammates i'm pretty sure all four of
them want to continue playing
i think they want to play on a team
together so maybe you'll see those four
with someone else but
i'm getting old man that is until the
right offer came around
i think i might have said that i wasn't
interested in playing and that is true
to an extent
it's more about who i was going to play
for and who with
if there was a good group of team or a
good group of players
and an organization that i felt as if i
could believe in
i could definitely see myself playing by
the time you know i
i couldn't see myself necessarily
leaving cloud 9 at the time
and after qualifying jack came to me and
told me i had this opportunity
to help build a new organization which
is now flyquest
a new organization that bought cloud9
second lcs spot for the 2017
season hai had finally left cloud nine
but this time he did it with his friends
he wasn't forced off fi quest may not
have had a spectacular
2017 but they were a respectable
middle of the pack team built on veteran
knowledge
and high shot calling by the time 2018
rolled around
it seemed impossible that hai would
stick around again
the franchised nalcs brought in new team
owners plenty of cash and star players
from around the world
and yet there was hai now leading the
golden guardians
golden guardians got off to an even
worse start than flyquest
but that doesn't necessarily tarnish
hai's career
at this point it seems unlikely that hai
will ever leave the lcs
at least not until he literally can't
play anymore
when am i gonna retire oh [ __ ]
wow you see that
has to be secret because one i don't
even know the answer to that
i i got enough to put you there dude who
knows
when i get tired of the game or when i
don't want to play anymore but for now i
want to play and i still like playing
hai is the mastermind behind c9 na's
most famous
and infamous shot-caller and the guy who
just
can't quit he's risen
fallen returned and
qualified for the lcs twice he's led
three teams
won two championships and he's still
hanging on
hai might be the most tenacious person
in the league of legends
and he's not going anywhere
it's time to make building your
champions easier
introducing the score esports new builds
calculator
which allows you to plug in items and
runes to figure out which builds give
you
the best stats the new builds page also
gathers information on what the top
players and your favorite pros are
building
so you'll be able to try them out
yourself take control of your champion
and try out the new feature on the score
esports builds website
by clicking on the link in the
description below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button